So I think that many times when you ask
an entrepreneur, when an entrepreneur
asks me what investors should I pick up,
or how should I choose my investors?
The first answer I give
them is just like that,
just like I expect you fast as possible.
You should expect your investors
to move the fast as possible.
In between getting a great
investor in three months, or
getting a good investor now,
go for the good investor now.
And then fulfill the rest of your needs
in terms of people that will help you
through advisors or anything else.
I think that this is good advice
in general, because as I said,
speed is the most important thing.
If you don't have money,
you cannot move.
In many cases,
you cannot hire more people.
And so this is really critical.
Having said that, you've gotta make
sure that you don't get investors in
that basically become
a liability on the company.
And the kind of investors that could
become a liability on the company,
are those that are either
very bad in the way they manage
the relationship with the founders.
That's one thing.
Or they will demand all kind of
terms that would basically take away
either the control of the destiny of
the company or slow down the company.
And so, when I see investors that
are requiring extreme veto rights,
or they're requiring to be
the ones approving stuff, or
investor I've even seen investor
that say I want to sign on
amounts of the company spends
above a certain level.
I stay away from these and
the reason is because as I said I wanted
the entrepreneur to be able to move
fast and interact fast, and if each such
movement and iteration is going to be
slowed down by investors that want to be
part of it, then the company's going to
have a liability that I don't like.
And so, all things equal,
go with good investors that move fast.
However, make sure that you
do not take money from people
that could become a liability.
How do you know that?
First of all, get a good lawyer.
And a good lawyer is not necessarily
one of the large firms, but
it's somebody that deals
with many start ups.
And make sure that the lawyer
explains to you what are the terms
that are in the contract that
are going to slow you down.
And these are the ones
you need to insist on,
on removing the ones that slow you down.
The second thing, never take money from
an investor without talking to at least
one company, preferably more,
that they invested in.
Just like the investor
due diligence is you,
you need to due diligence
them because that's marriage.
They are going to be together for
years now.
And so, if you're not going to basically
talk to somebody that already worked
with them and get honest review of them,
then you're not doing yourself justice.
And just like an investor
is not doing its job
if they're not doing due
diligence in the company,
you're on the doing your job if you
not due diligence in the investors.
And after all of that,
when you get the list of people
that passed your due diligence and
that are willing to move fast, only then
start thinking about who's the best.
Only then start thinking about
who can help me the most and
who can bring me the most value.
And then, when you think about who can
bring me the most value, it's important
to not think about who brings me the
most value hands on, because you don't
want your investors to be hands on with
the business that you're building.
It's two things, is who gives me
the most credibility in the market.
Because let's say that you're building
an open table like business, and
if you've got an investor which is an
open table x executive that brings you
lots of credibility with investors.
So, that's one thing
that can bring you value.
The other thing is if you
get access to their network.
So, look at the network of the person.
These are the two things to look for.
Credibility that it gives you,
a network that you can use.